so that was an incredible experience
uh can you maybe speak to what kind of
opportunities that opens up that stream
of data that rich stream of data from
the brain
first i i'm curious what is your
reaction what
what comes to mind when you put that on
your head what does it mean to you
and what possibilities emerge and what
significance might it have i mean i'm
curious where
your orientation is at well
for me i'm really excited by the
possibility of
various information about my body about
my mind
being converted into data such that data
can be used to create products
that make my life better so that that
means really exciting possibility
even just like a fitbit that measures i
don't know
some very basic measurements about your
body is really cool
but it's the the bandwidth of
information
the resolution of that information is
very crude so it's not very interesting
the possibility of recording of just
building a data set
coming in a clean way in a high
bandwidth way from
my brain opens up uh
all kinds of you know at the very i was
kind of joking when we're talking but
it's not really it's like i feel heard
in the sense that it feels like
the full richness of the information
coming from my mind
is actually being recorded by the
machine i mean there's a i can't
i can't quite put it into words but
there is genuinely for me
there's not some kind of joke about me
being a robot is this genuinely feels
like i'm being
heard in a way that uh
that's going to improve my life as long
as the thing that's on the other end
can do something useful with that data
but even the the recording itself
is like once you record it's like taking
a picture
that moment is forever saved in time
now picture cannot allow you to step
back
into that world but perhaps
recording your brain is a much higher
resolution thing
much more personal recording of that
information in a picture
that would allow you to step back into
that uh
where you were in that particular moment
in history
and then map out a certain trajectory to
tell you certain things about
uh about yourself that could open up all
kinds of applications of course there's
health
that i consider but honestly to me the
exciting thing is just being heard
my state of mind the level of focus all
those kinds of things
being heard what i heard you say is you
have an entirety
of lived experience some of which you
can communicate in words
and in body language some of which you
feel internally
which cannot be captured in those
communication modalities and that this
measurement system
captures both the things you can try to
articulate in words maybe in a lower
dimensional
space using one word for example to
communicate focus
yeah when it really may be represented
in a 20 dimensional space of this
particular kind of focus and that this
information is being captured
so it's a closer representation to the
entirety
of your experience captured in a dynamic
fashion that it's not just a
static image of your conscious
experience
yeah yeah that that's that's that's the
promise that's the hope that was the
feeling
and it felt like the future so it's a
pretty cool experience and from the
sort of uh mechanical perspective it was
cool to
have an actual device that feels pretty
good
that doesn't uh doesn't require me to go
into the lab
and also the other thing i was i was
feeling there's a guy named andrew
huberman he's a friend of mine amazing
podcast people should uh
should listen to a huberman lab podcast
we're working on a paper together
about eye movement and so on and we're
kind of he's a neuroscientist and i'm a
data person machine learning person and
we're we're both excited by
how much the that
how much the data measurements of the
human mind
the brain and all the different metrics
that come from that
can be used to understand human beings
and
in a rigorous scientific way so the
other thing i was thinking about is how
this could be turned into
a tool for science sort of not just
personal science not just like
fitbit style like how am i doing
my personal metrics of health but doing
larger scale studies of human behavior
and so on
so like data not at the scale of an
individual but data at a scale of many
individuals or a large number of
individuals so
so it's personal being heard was
exciting and also just for science it's
exciting
it's very easy like there's a very
powerful thing to it being so easy to
just put on
that uh you can scale much easier if you
think about that second thing you said
about
the science of
the brain most
we've done a pretty good job like we the
human race has done a pretty good job
figuring out how to quantify the things
around us from distance
stars to calories and steps and
our genome so we can measure and
quantify pretty much
everything in the known universe except
for our minds
and we can do these one-offs if we're
going to get an fmri scan or
do something with the low-res eeg system
but we haven't done this at
population scale and so if you think
about
human thought or human cognition is
probably
the single law uh largest raw input
material into society at any given
moment
it's our conversations with our with
ourselves and with other people
and we have this this raw input that we
can't haven't been able to measure yet
yeah
and if you when i think about it through
that frame
it's remarkable it's almost like we live
in this
wild wild west of unquantified
communications within ourselves and
between each other
when everything else has been grounded
me for example i know if i buy an
appliance at this
at the store or on a website i don't
need to
look at the measurements on the
appliance make sure it can fit through
my door
that's an engineered system of appliance
manufacturing and
construction everyone's agreed upon
engineering standards
and we don't have engineering standards
around cognition it's not a for it has
not entered as a formal
engineering discipline that enables us
to scaffold in society with everything
else we're doing
including consuming news our
relationships
politics economics education all the
above
and so to me that the most significant
contribution that kernel technology has
to offer
would be the formal sca the
introduction to formal engineering of
cognition as it relates to everything
else in society
i love that i idea that you kind of
think
that there is just this ocean of data
that's coming from people's brains as
being in a crude way reduced down to
like
tweets and texts and so on so it's a
very uh
hardcore many scale compression of
actual the raw data but maybe you can
comment
because you use the word cognition
i think the first step is to get the
brain data
but um is there a leap
to be taking to sort of interpreting
that data in terms of cognition
so as your is your idea is basically you
need to start collecting data at scale
from the brain and then we start to
really be able to
take little steps along the path to
actually
measuring some deep sense of cognition
because
it's you know as i'm sure you know we
don't
we understand a few things but we don't
understand most of
what makes up cognition this has been
one of the most significant challenges
of building kernel and colonel wouldn't
exist if i wasn't able to fund it
initially by myself
because when i engage in conversations
with investors
the immediate thought is what is the
killer app
and of course i understand that
heuristic that's what they're looking at
is they're looking to de-risk
is the product solved is there a
customer base are people willing to pay
for it how does it compare to competing
options
and in the case with brain interfaces
when i started the company
there was no known path to even build a
technology that could potentially
become mainstream and then once we
figured out the technology
we could even we could commence having
conversations with investors and it
became
what is the killer app and so what has
been
so i funded the first 53 million dollars
of the company
and to raise the round of funding the
first one we did i spoke to 228
investors
one said yes it was remarkable and it
was
mostly around this concept around what
is a killer app and
so internally the way we think about it
is we think of the
the go to market strategy much more like
the drake equation
where if we can build technology that
has the characteristics of
it has the data quality is high enough
it meets some certain threshold
cost accessibility comfort
it can be worn in contextual
environments if it meets the criteria
of being a mass-market device then
the responsibility that we have is to
figure out how to
create the algorithm that enables
the human to enable
uh humans to then find value with it
okay so it so the analogy is is like
brain interfaces are like early 90s of
the internet is you
you want to populate an ecosystem with a
certain number of devices you want a
certain number of people
who play around with them who do
experiments of certain data collection
parameters you want to encourage certain
mistakes
from experts and non-experts these are
all critical elements
that ignite discovery and so
we believe we've accomplished the first
objective of building technology
that reaches those thresholds and now
it's the drake equation component
of how do we
try to generate
20 years of value discovery in a two or
three year time period how do we
compress that
so just to clarify so when you mean the
drake equation
uh which for people who don't know i
don't know why you if you listen to this
i bring up aliens every single
conversation so
it's i don't know how you would know
what the drake equation is but you mean
like the killer app it would be one
alien civilization in that equation so
meaning like
this is in search of an application
that's impactful transformative
by the way it should be we need to come
up with a better term than killer app
as a it's it's also violent right very
violent
you can go like viral app that's
horrible too right it's some
very uh inspiringly impactful
application
how about that no yeah okay so but let's
stick with killer app that's fine
nobody's but i concur with you i dislike
the chosen words in in capturing the
concept
you know it's one of those sticky things
that is as
effective to use in the tech world but
when you
now become a a communicator outside of
the tech world especially when you're
talking about
software and hardware and artificial
intelligence applications it sounds
horrible yeah it's interesting i i
actually regret now having called
attention because i regret having used
that word in this conversation
because it's something i would not
normally do i i used it
in order to create a bridge of shared
understanding of how others would what
terminology others would use
yeah but yeah i concur let's go with the
impactful application value creation
value creation something people love
using
there we go love app
okay so what uh do you have any ideas
you're basically creating a framework
where there's
the possibility of a discovery of uh
an application that people love using
is do you have ideas we've began to play
a fun game internally where when we have
these discussions and we
begin circling around this concept of
does anybody have an idea does anyone
have intuitions and
if we see the conversation starting to
to veer in that direction
we flag it and say human intuition alert
stop it and so we really want to focus
on the algorithm
of there's a natural process of human
discovery
that when you populate a system with
devices and you give people the
opportunity to play around with it in
expected and unexpected ways
we are thinking that is a much better
system of discovery
than us exercising tuitions and it's
interesting we're also seeing a few
neural scientists who have been
have been talking to us where i was
speaking just one young
associate professor and i approached a
conversation and said hey
we have these five data streams that
we're pulling off
when you hear that what weighted value
do you add to each data source like
which one do you think is going to be
valuable for your objectives
and which one's not and he said i don't
care just give me the data
all i care about is my machine learning
model but importantly he did not have a
theory of mind he did not
come to the table and say i think the
brain operates you know with in this way
and these regions
have these these functions he didn't
care he just wanted the data and we're
seeing that more and more
that certain people
are devaluing human intuitions for good
reasons as we've seen in machine
learning over
over the past couple years and we're
doing the same in our value creation
uh market strategy
so more collect more data clean data
make uh the products such that the
collection of data is uh
easy and and and fun and then the
the rest will just spring to life
that's right through humans playing
around with them our objective is to
create
the most valuable
data collection system of the brain ever
and with that then applying all the
best tools of machine learning and other
techniques to extract out you know
to try to find insight but yes our
objective is really to systematize the
discovery process because we
we can't put definite time frames on
discovery
the brain is complicated and and science
is not a business strategy and so we
really need to figure out how to
this is the difficulty of bringing
bringing you know technology like this
to market it's why
most of the time it just ling it
languishes
in academia academia for quite some time
but we hope that
we will over you know cross over and
make this mainstream in the coming years
the thing was cool to wear but what's uh
are you chasing a good reason for
millions of people to put
this on their head and keep on their
head regularly
is there like who's going to discover
that reason
is it going to be people just kind of
organically
or is there going to be a angry bird
style application
that's just uh too exciting to
to not use if i think through the things
that
have changed my life most significantly
over the past few years when i started
wearing
a wearable in my wrist that would give
me data about my heart rate heart rate
variability respiration rate
metabolic approximations etc
for the first time in my life i had
access to information
sleep patterns that were highly
impactful they
they told me for example if i eat close
to bedtime
i'm not going to get deep sleep and not
getting deep sleep means you have all
these follow-on consequences in life and
so
it opened up this window of
understanding of myself
that i cannot self-introspect and deduce
these things this is information that
was
available to be acquired but it just
wasn't i would have to
get an expensive sleep study then it's
an end like one night and that's not
good enough to look
to run all my trials and so if you look
just at the information
that one can acquire on their wrist and
now you're
planted to the entire cortex on the
brain and you say what kind of
information could we acquire
it opens up a whole new universe of
possibilities
for example we did this internal study
at kernel where i wore a prototype
device
and we were measuring the cognitive
effects of sleep
so i had a device measuring my sleep i
performed with 13 of my
my coworkers we performed four cognitive
tasks
over 13 sessions and we focused on
reaction time impulse control
uh short term memory and then a resting
state task
and we with mine we found for example
that
my impulse control was
independently correlated with my sleep
outside of behavioral measures of my
ability to play the game
the point of the study was i had
the brain study i did at colonel
confirmed my life experience
that if i my deep sleep
determined whether or not i would be
able to resist
temptation the following day and my
brain didn't show that
as one example and so if you start
thinking if you actually have
uh data on yourself on your on your
entire cortex and you can control the
the settings
i think there's probably an uh a
large number of things that we could
discover about ourselves very very small
and very very big
i just for example like when you read
news
what's going on like when you use social
media when you use news
what like all the ways we allocate
attention that's right
with the computer i mean that seems like
a compelling place to where you would
want to put on uh kernel by the way what
is it called kernel flux kernel like
what flow
fluid yeah two technologies uh flow flow
okay so when you when you put on the the
kernel flow
it it is seems like to be um
a complete a compelling time and place
to do it is when you're behind a desk
behind a computer
because you could probably wear it for
prolonged periods of time
as you're as you're taking in content
and there could a lot of
because some of our so much of our lives
happens in the digital world now
that kind of coupling the information
about the human mind
with the consumption and the behaviors
in the digital world might give us a lot
of information about the effects
of the way we behave and navigate the
digital world to the actual physical
meat
space uh effects on our body it's
interesting to think
so in terms of both like for work i
i'm a big fan of uh cal newport his
ideas of deep work
that i spend uh
with few exceptions i try to spend the
first two hours of every day
usually if i'm like at home and have
nothing on my schedule is
going to be up to eight hours of deep
work of focus
zero distraction and for me to analyze
the i mean i'm very
aware of the uh the waning of that
ups and downs of that and it's almost
like you you're surfing
the ups and downs of that as you're
doing programming as you're doing
thinking about particular problems
you're trying to visualize things in
your mind you
start trying to stitch them together
you're trying to uh
when there's a dead end about an idea
you have to kind of
calmly like walk back and start again
all those kinds of processes
it'd be interesting to get data on what
my mind is actually doing
and also recently started doing um i
just talked to
sam harris a few days ago and been
building up to that i started using
started meditating using his app uh
waking up but
very much uh recommend it and be
interested to get data on that
because it's you're very it's like
you're removing all the noise
from your head and you're very much it's
an active process of
active noise removal active noise
cancelling
like the headphones and it'd be
interesting to see what is going on in
the mind
before the meditation during it and
after all those kinds of things
and in all of your examples it's
interesting that
everyone who's designed an experience
for you so whether it be the meditation
app
or the deep work or with all the things
you mentioned
they constructed this product with a
certain
number of knowns yeah now what if
we expanded the number of knowns by 10x
or 20x or 30x
they would reconstruct their product
cool incorporate those known so it'd be
yeah and so this is the dimensionality
that i think is the promising aspect is
that people will be able to use this
quantification
use this information to build more
effective products
and this is i'm not talking about better
products to advertise
to you or manipulate you i'm talking
about uh
our focus is helping people individuals
have this contextual awareness and
quantification and then to engage with
others who are
seeking to improve people's lives that
the objective is
is betterment across ourselves
individually and also uh with each other
yeah so it's a nice data stream to have
if you're building an
app like if you're building a podcast
listening app it would be nice to know
data about the listener
so that like if you're bored or you fell
asleep maybe pause the podcast
like really dumb just very simple
applications
that could just improve the quality of
the experience of the using the app
i'm imagining if you have you have your
norm this is lex
and you there's a statistical
representation of you
and you engage with the app and it says
lex
your best to engage with this meditation
exercise in the following settings at
this time of day
after eating this kind of food or not
eaten fasting
with this level of blood glucose and
this kind of night's sleep
but all these data combined
to give you this contextually relevant
experience just like we do with our
sleep we you've optimized your entire
life
based upon what information you can
acquire and know about yourself
and so the question is how much do we
really know of the things going around
us and i would venture to guess in my
own
my life life experience i capture my
self-awareness captures an extremely
small
percent of the things that actually
influence my conscious
and unconscious experience well in some
sense the data would
help encourage you to be more self-aware
not just because you
trust everything the data is saying but
is it'll give you a prod to start
investigating
like i would love to get like a a rating
like a ranking of all the things i do
and what are the things this is probably
important to do without the data
but the data will certainly help it's
like rank all the things you do in life
and which ones make you feel shitty
which must make you feel good
like uh you're talking about evening
brian like uh this
is a good example somebody like i do pig
out at night as
as well and uh and it
never makes like you're in a safe space
it is this is just a safe space
let's hear it no i i definitely have
much less self-control at night
and it's interesting and the same you
know um
people might criticize this but i i know
my own body
i know when i eat carnivores just eat
meat i feel much better
than uh if i eat more
more carbs the more cubs i eat the worse
i feel i don't know why that is
i don't i there is science supporting
but i'm not leading on science i'm
leaning on personal experience and
that's really important
i don't need to read i'm not going to go
on a whole rant about nutrition science
but
many of those studies are very flawed
they're doing their best but nutrition
science is a very difficult
field of study because humans are so
different
and the mind has so much impact on the
way your body
behaves and it's so difficult from a
scientific perspective to conduct really
strong studies
that you have to be almost like a
scientist of an
of one you have to do these studies on
yourself that's the best way to
understand what works for you or not
and i don't understand why because it
sounds unhealthy but eating only meat
always makes me feel good
just eat eat meat that's it and i don't
have any allergies any of that kind of
stuff
i'm not full like jordan peterson where
like if he like deviates a little bit
that he goes off like deviates a little
bit from the carnivore diet he goes off
like the cliff no i can i can have like
chalk i can
i can go off the diet i feel fine it's
not it's a it's a gradual
uh uh it's a gradual worsening
of how i feel but what i eat only meat i
feel great
and it'd be nice to be reminded of that
like there's a very simple fact
that i feel good when i eat carnivore
and i think that repeats itself in all
kinds of
experiences like i feel really good
when i exercise not i hate exercise
okay but in the rest of the day the
the uh the impact it has on my mind and
the clarity of mind and the
experiences and the happiness and all
those kinds of things i feel really good
and to be able to concretely express
that through data would be
would be nice it would be a nice
reminder almost like a statement like
remember what feels good and what not
and there could be things like
uh that i'm not many things like just
you're suggesting that i could not be
aware of
there might be sitting right in front of
me that uh make me feel really good and
make me feel not good
and the data would show that i agree
with you i've actually
employed the same strategy i i fired my
mind entirely
from being responsible for constructing
my diet
so i started doing a program where i now
track over 200 biomarkers
every 90 days and it captures
of course the things you would expect
like cholesterol but also dna
methylation
and all kinds of things about my body
all the processes that make up
me and then i let that data generate the
shopping
and so i never actually ask my mind what
it wants it's entirely what my body is
reporting that it wants and so i call
this
goal alignment within brian and there's
200
plus actors that i'm currently asking
their opinion of and so i'm asking my
liver how are you doing
and it's expressing via the biomarkers
and so then i construct that diet
and i only eat those foods until my next
testing round
and that has changed my life more than i
think anything else
because in the emotion of my conscious
mind that i gave primacy to my entire
life it led me astray because like
you're saying
the mind then goes out into the world
and it navigates
the dozens of different dietary regimens
people put together in books and it all
has
their al has their supporting science in
certain contextual settings but it's not
n of one
and like you're saying this dietary
really is an end of one
these what people have published
scientifically of course can be used
uh for nice groundings but
it changes when you end up one level and
so that's what gets me excited about
brainerd faces is if you
if i could do the same thing for my
brain where i can stop asking my
conscious mind
for its advice or for its decision
making which is
flawed and i'd rather just look at this
data that and i've never had better
health markers in my life than when i
stopped
actually asking myself to be in charge
of it and
the idea of uh the motion of the
conscious mind
is uh is such a sort of engineering way
of phrasing like meditation with what
they mean that's what we're doing right
yeah that's beautiful that means really
beautifully put
by the way testing round what does that
look like what's that
well you mentioned uh yeah the very the
test i do
yes so includes a complete blood panel
i do a microbiome test i do a food
inflammation of diet induced
inflammation so i look for excito kind
expressions
so foods that produce inflammatory
reactions
i look at my neural endocrine systems i
look at all my neurotransmitters
uh i do uh yeah there's several
micronutrient tests to see how i'm
looking at the very various nutrients
what about like
self report of like how you feel
you know almost like um
you can't demote your con you still
exist within your conscious mind
mm-hmm right so that that lived
experience of is
of a lot of value i do measure that i do
a temporal sampling
over some duration of time so i'll think
through how i feel
over a week over a month over three
months i don't do a temporal sampling of
if i'm at the grocery store in front of
a cereal box and be like
you know what captain crunch is probably
the right thing for me today because i'm
feeling like
i need a little fun in my life yeah and
so it's a temporal sampling if the data
sets large enough then i i smooth out
the function
of my natural oscillations of how i feel
about life where some days i may
feel upset or depressed or down or
whatever and i don't want those moments
to then rule my decision making that's
why
the demotion happens and it says really
if you're looking at health over 90 day
period of time
all my 200 voices speak up on that
interval and
they're all given voice to say this is
how i'm doing and this is what i want
and so it really is an accounting system
for everybody so that's why
i think that if you think about the
future of being human
there's two things i think that are
really going on
one is the design manufacturing and
distribution of intelligence
is heading towards zero con a cost curve
over a certain design over a certain
time frame
but our ability to you know evolution
produced us
an intelligent form of intelligence we
are now designing our own intelligence
systems
and the design manufacturing
distribution of that intelligence over a
certain
uh time frame is going to go to a cost
of zero
design manufacture distribution of
intelligent
cost is going to zero again
just give me a second okay that's
brilliant okay
and evolution is doing the design
manufacturing distribution of
intelligence
and now we are doing the design
manufacturing distribution of
intelligence
and the cost of that is going to zero
that's a very
uh nice way of looking at life on earth
so if that that's going on and then now
in parallel
to that then you say okay what
what then happens if when that cost
curve is heading
to zero our existence becomes
a goal alignment problem a goal
alignment
function and so the same thing i'm doing
where i'm doing go alignment within
myself of these 200 biomarkers where i'm
saying
when when brian exists on a daily basis
and this entity is deciding what to eat
and what to do and et cetera
it's not just my conscious mind which is
opining it's
200 biological processes and there's a
whole bunch more voices
involved so in that equation
we're going to increasingly automate
the things that we spend high energy on
today that's easier and now we're going
to then
negotiate the terms and conditions of
intelligent life
now we say conscious existence because
we're biased because that's what we have
but it will be the largest computational
exercise in history because you're now
doing
goal alignment with planet earth within
yourself
with each other within all the
intelligent agents we're building
bots and other you know voice assistants
you basically i don't have a trillions
and trillions of agents
working on the negotiation of goal
alignment
yeah this this is in fact true uh
and what was the second thing that was
it so the cost
the design manufacturing distribution of
intelligence going to zero
which then means what's really going on
what are we really doing
we're negotiating the terms and
conditions
of existence
you